this video was brought to you by brain
blast games they were a huge donator for
our charity Save the Children campaign
and donated over 50,000 go ahead and
support them for supporting us bros they
make sweet iOS games and I'll leave a
link in the description
Hasegawa as my name's peter pan and
welcome to Friday Bearpaw it's Sunday
right what are you gonna do we're gonna
do a Q&A because anyway let's do it when
did you start your prostitution service
it started back in 2002 what I mean I
don't have a prostitution service I want
to ask you something about this picture
well it just proves that I will be
fabulous as a girl I don't know what to
say what is the weirdest / ugliest face
that you can make if it's possible with
your fabulous face I'll stop it I don't
know I can't see from here but I assume
it's pretty nice if you could dye your
hair any color what would it be pink
it's a special effect working does it
look good yeah if you would turn gay for
one day who would be your partner /
boyfriend oh you know hey there are you
doing pretty good
have you ever tasted earwax no oh god I
discussing
do you gotta Bay hey is there a funny
story when you're on your birthday with
my chair
mium I said and really we were used to
speaking online so when we met on our
first date we went really late to a
romantic restaurant and we would still
write to each other on on tiny tiny
pieces of paper instead of a big [ __ ]
it was really cute I really really it's
a nice memory what can you say about
this that is that is hot laughs in a way
you never laughed before again it's not
a question
all right that's how I laugh when I'm
drunk if you could describe yourself
with one word what would it be if you
could have a superpower what would it be
it would be to have erect nipples
whenever I so desired oh wait I already
had that superpower what what what is
happening oh my gosh do you see this oh
I'm so happy right now would you rather
have fingers the size of your legs or
legs the size of your fingers let's
check it out
mmm that's pretty hot that's also very
hot I'm gonna have to go with both what
color is your bra um actually in it I
mean I'm not wearing a bra if you and
Justin Bieber had a baby what would you
name him Satan have you ever been
punched in the face by a kawaii potato
No can you not cut your hair for three
years
all that's sweet you know what I'm I'm
I'm know so me are you gonna do about it
to be honest I really don't know what
you ask I just want to be in your video
well with that icon I can't help myself
write your name without using your thumb
great question
amazing question all right this thing
has a touchscreen yeah so um all right
let me do this yeah right then beautiful
it's too bright that's all the question
I had time for today Brea's if there's
any other question go ahead and leave a
comment and I'll try and answer as many
as I can go ahead and leave a like if
you enjoyed watching and as always bros
thank you for being a bro you Brooke you
bros are the best bros in the bro verse
catacombs video it's gonna come up
mid-august I've been getting a lot of
questions about it and that's it
like I said thanks for being a bro and
thank you for being awesome here's the
brofist for ya